book TV continues now with Stephen Hill
who looks at how digital technology and
the growth of companies such as uber and
air B&B is affecting the American
workforce
[Music]
yeah I think we should get started we're
already five minutes over so welcome I'm
David Howell and I'll be stepping in I'm
not Janet Gornick I'll be stepping in
for Janet who couldn't make it because
of family matters and I'll be
introducing this conversation between
Eduardo Porter an exceptional columnist
for The New York Times and Steven hill
about Steve's new book raw deal how the
uber economy and Naked Capitalism are
screwing American workers in addition to
being an old friend and colleague of
Janet's pardon me I'm going to read this
because I've got a five minute limit and
it's already probably seven so I'm gonna
try to do this quickly in addition to
being an old friend and colleague of
Janet's I'm a professor at the new
school right down Fifth Avenue
specializing in labor economics and
Social Policy this year I have a
privilege of being here at the Graduate
Center as an arc Fellow and as a list
Center visiting scholar so arc stands
for advance research collaborative on
which Eduardo is a board member and this
stands for the Luxembourg income study
so this event is sponsored by lists the
list center here at CUNY's Graduate
Center which Janet directs this is
pioneered the development of consistent
cross national data for the study of
income distribution and poverty it's a
data center that serves a global
community of researchers educators and
policy makers now I get to say what
Janet would not say which is that under
her leadership list has taken off to
dramatically higher levels of prominence
for the study of income inequality which
is increasingly recognized as one of the
most serious social problems in the
modern era and the reason most of you
are here today tonight she's helped
enlist the renowned English economist
Anthony Atkinson
who long ago should have won the Nobel
Prize as the president of the list board
and she played a central role in
bringing Paul
egman who did win the Nobel Prize to
lists and the Graduate Center and of
course he's also a hugely influential in
New York Times columnist and colleague
of Eduardo's she also helped bring
Branko Milanovic till this from the
World Bank Bronco is without doubt one
of the top researchers in the world on
global income inequality and according
to my students also a fabulous teacher
and she helps put on great events like
this one so welcome Eduardo Porter and
Stephen Hill if you don't read Porter's
New York Times column religiously every
Wednesday you're making a very big
mistake on a variety of topics from
income inequality to technological
change in jobs to education and wages to
the crazy American politics of global
warming Porter's columns are great
incredibly rich with information and
balanced in perspective although if I
like him so much perhaps they're not
perfectly balanced I am a new-school
economist after all we're very fortunate
to have Stephen Hill here to talk about
his new book raw deal Stephens a senior
fellow with a new America Foundation and
a Holtz brink fellow at the American
Academy in Berlin he's a veteran
journalist and author of five books
including the internationally praised
Europe's promise why the European Way is
the best hope in an insecure age which
was selected as one of the top 15 books
of 2010 by the globalist so a raw deal
is an important and incredibly timely
book and it happens also to be important
and timely for me I'm here at the
Graduate Center working on what I call
the decent wage project funded by the
Washington Center for equitable growth
the project aims to document in great
demographic detail the spectacular
growth in lousy jobs and consequently
the decline in decent ones that we've
seen since in the post 1980 neoliberal
policy era our big questions are
how do we the US compared to five other
large rich diverse countries in the
translation of economic growth into
decent jobs what explains our decent job
performance and what or lack of it and
what lessons can we learn from the
recent experiences of Canada the UK
Australia Germany and France in the
earlier post-war Golden Age period
economists could just call from more
growth and be confident that it would
trickle down throughout the workforce
and across the income distribution but
since about 1980 there's been virtually
no sharing of economic growth it's all
gone to the top 10% and mostly to the
top 1% the Republican presidential
candidates continue in their knee-jerk
fashion see how balanced I am to call
for tax cuts to spur growth to solve the
inequality and low wage problems but
whatever you think about the
effectiveness of tax cuts and yes
Eduardo has also written brilliantly
about this the simple fact is that from
the point of view of the bottom half of
the wage distribution changes in the
growth rate don't matter much since
economic growth hasn't been shared and
we are also experiencing a decline and
redistribution through social spending
from the top to the middle and bottom in
some there's been a profound underlying
ideological shift of free market
fundamentalism which has led to policy
and corporate governance choices that
have dramatically weakened worker
bargaining power that's the vision that
frames our project and that's what
you're going to be hearing about in
Steven Hills discussion with the way
Eduardo and the book you're going to
read so for me Stevens Hills book
promises to be a tremendous resource
detailing at a granular level how this
process has worked out while pointing
the way to how workers can once again
share in our nation's productivity
growth Eduardo and Steven will now have
a conversation about the book and the
issues raised by it I will join you in
the audience here and then at 7:30 sharp
if not before I'll return up here and
help to manage the question and answers
answer part of the
discussion for which we've been
allocated 15 minutes till quarter to
eight and at that point Steve will sign
books starting with mine thanks hi good
evening guys hi Steve
thanks a lot for the introduction Steve
has offered us as it has written up a
really great impassioned book he's
offering us like a technological
dystopia that pushes hard against you
know the libertarian happy talk that one
hear so often from Silicon Valley about
how technology is going to be great for
all and deliver this fantastically
prosperous world and it's it's it has a
really strong proposition that I'd like
to read to you like in a nutshell what
if smart machines and robots could
perform every single job there is to do
and sharing economy websites Cadell
deliver all the services and goods so
that no human had to work at a job
anymore who would reap the benefit of
this unimaginably enormous productivity
increase so this is the question that he
sets out the answer and he does it very
interestingly mixing in enormous ly
detailed accounts of real people some of
which actually have struck very near
home to me I'm a journalist I make a
living out of writing and you got this
story of this you know Pulitzer Prize
winning photographer that suddenly loses
his job in San Francisco and suddenly
has to resort to you know to renting out
bits of his home on Airbnb and driving
people around in his car via uber and
considering renting out his equipment
via some other web staring a site and so
if that's happening to journalists then
the world is really going into a bad
place so but my question is here is is
it's hard to tell how how significant
these different examples or these
different dynamics happening in certain
markets and in
with certain services is this does this
really look like the way for the future
on a massive scale for our labor market
or maybe this is more of an exception I
mean how do you feel about this really
becoming the norm of work well you know
whenever you're trying to sift through
huge amounts of data and stories and and
and then sort of project where we are
today and where we'll be ten years from
now 20 years now I mean everyone's got
their crystal ball out and and no one
knows who's gonna be right but what I
wanted to do in this book was I wanted
to make it really clear what's at stake
you know everyone can agree on that
we're about to go through a
transformation of our economy our
society technology is going to be used
in a way that penetrates into every
corner of our lives in a way that we
never would have conceived of they're
gonna be wanting to put things into our
bodies nanobots that are going to keep
track of our health they're gonna want
to you know have our cars that drive
themselves they're going to want you
know I mean on and on and on you
probably have seen all you've read
different stories and so I was looking
at all these different threads of this
of the the dialogue that's been going on
and wanted to put it all together into
some sort of picture in which it was
clear of what's what's at stake you know
my fear is that we're gonna look back 20
years from now and we're gonna say wow
we didn't get that right we didn't put
the right rules and regulations around
the technologies that are coming and the
companies who are pushing them to make
sure that we end up with a society that
works for all of us instead of just for
a handful because as that part you read
you know if we have all these
unimaginable labor productivity
increases you know who will benefit
whose pockets will that flow into if
when we look at the last 30 years in
fact I was doing a radio show not too
long ago and somebody said you know this
some are talking about there'll be a
guaranteed minimum livable wage twenty
five thirty thousand dollars a year I
mean what would be wrong
that if we all got 25 $30,000 liver and
then we could all do our art and our
culture and all these sorts of things I
said they haven't even given you a pay
increase in the last 25 years you know
the political system hasn't managed to
harness the economic system in a way to
make that happen
so what makes you think that somehow the
political system is going to somehow
harness the economic system oh wait it's
going to turn over a guaranteed livable
wage to anybody you know without more
more struggle and more people getting
involved and saying this is not right
this is not good so you know that's you
know fundamentally what I wanted to
write about in the book and to do that I
looked at a lot of people's stories as
you said Chris Young an auto worker in
in Tennessee working for Nissan he's
working doing the exact same job as the
Nissan worker who's got the Nissan shirt
on but he doesn't have the Nissan shirt
because he's working for a contractor
and he's doing the exact same job he's
getting half the pay barely any safety
net at all he's you know has no job
security you probably a lot of you've
heard about Google buses and such out in
San Francisco and Facebook buses what
you haven't heard about is the drivers
that drive those buses they don't work
for Google and Facebook they work for a
contractor and that contractor has told
them you've got a report to work by 5:30
in the morning and you're not your data
is an end till 9:30 at night you don't
get to see your kids when you wake up in
the morning or when you come home at
night because they're already in bed for
school and so they don't violate the
federal wage laws about how many hours
you can work a day they make them take
four hours off in the middle of the day
and and they don't live close enough
most of them to go home for those four
hours they don't allow them to get a
second job during those four hours so
they just have to hang around the
parking lot they're basically indentured
servant in an indentured servitude these
sorts of jobs so there's lots of stories
about people like this as they are
grappling with these trends in our
economy that are you know for a lot of
people are not working I even have a
quote from Tina Brown and they're you
know the media mogul where she says you
know
me a lot of my friends we all started
doing the you know the freelance thing
and it's you know for the first six
months everyone says oh it's great I
love the flexibility she says a year
later no one writes that store
anymore so this is you know these are
the things that are happening and in
fact I just recently heard the craziest
job that I have heard of this new ilk I
don't know if you talked about it in the
book I didn't see it here I heard it on
the radio was this service called
invisible girlfriend where people will
you know be your well this service will
be your girlfriend and it turns out that
it can be very many people that are just
texting you earning pennies on the text
to say yes honey I love you or you know
let's meet up later or something so that
you can show your friends that you have
a girlfriend right I right I do write
about this not that particular business
but you know in the sharing economy also
now known as the gig economy on-demand
economy peer-to-peer economy it's got
all these names you have gigs that's
what's called gig is just you know you
contract with someone through this
service whether it's uber lyft
TaskRabbit to do various odd jobs and
then they come up with micro gigs
because the algorithms are getting so
good at squishing jobs down and just
smaller and smaller bits so they can pay
you for smaller and smaller bits and now
they have nano gigs nano gigs are you go
on place place like Mechanical Turk on
Amazon and others and you can do jobs
where you identify photos from for 5
cents a photo and you identify so when
people doing searches on your search
engines and you type in a keyword its
assigns that word to you no particular
type of shoes pointed shoes rounded
shoes a handbag with brown handbag
that's black a cat lying on a carpet a
cat lying on a couch they're just
assigning these different terms to
photos and in fact here's the beauty get
ready for this you can do it in your
spare time
they call it monetizing your down time
how about that how about that monetizing
your Downton you could do it standing in
line at Starbucks you can do it while
you're waiting on the bus you can do it
if you're waiting at the doctor's office
you can why waste time what good is
spare time it's who needs that doesn't
pay anything you can sit there
identifying photos and getting you know
you're ready to pay will be about two or
three dollars per hour if you're good
you know so these are the Nano gigs that
they have lined up for I mean use the
other thing to keep in mind when it
comes especially comes to the share and
Kearney gig economy stuff and
and you know lift and TaskRabbit they
the thing that they don't want to
address and I tried to get them to
address it is that you know if you work
for a traditional job you go to that job
and you're paid say nine to five and
everything you do between those hours is
paid time that includes meetings with
your coworkers that means you know a
lunch break or a well maybe my lunch
break but a break that you get it means
you know time talking in the hallway
with your coworkers brainstorming ideas
that means just hanging around the water
cooler for a little bit that's all paid
time in this new gig economy you're not
getting paid for anything the only time
you're paid for is the time you were
absolutely productive producing that
report producing that image if you're a
graphic designer you know it'd be as if
Eli Manning was paid only when he throws
a touchdown pass which hasn't been
happening very much lately I guess so he
would his pay would be low indeed you
know you're only being paid for that
productive time this is a profound
transformation of how we conceive of
work that they are proposing to us as a
society to say that this is how we
should construct work going forward
because this is what they're saying is
and what they'll tell you is like it's
liberating you to have more flexibility
you'll get to work when you want you
don't want to work you turn off the app
right you know they're trying to say
uber drivers have all this flexibility
but and there's a certain degree of
truth to that if you you know if you
only need to do a part-time but I mean
I've interviewed a lot of drivers for
this book and what you see is that those
drivers who drive at the least it have
been driving at the shortest are the
happiest the ones who have been doing it
for a while and have been you know there
for a year in fact ubers own numbers
show half the drivers don't last for a
year they leave the platform because
after you've gone through a few of
Travis County X's pay cuts which come on
a regular basis you know you after a
while you think like I'm not making as
much money as I did when I started to
say you move on so this is just a lot of
factors like that I think that I'd be I
was really interested in identifying the
role of the technology in this because
we've had bad jobs in the economy for a
very long time and especially over the
last you know a couple of decades we've
developed in the retail sector
you know an enormous amount of bad jobs
like the Starbucks employee who gets you
know a shift till 11:00 one night and
the next day stars at 4:00 you him in
the morning and he barely has time to
get home and come back to work so and
and I've seen some pushback against the
notion that the gig economy is causing a
significant part of this bad work and
some stats have been have been have been
deployed in this so for instance the
number of part-time workers have not
really gone up over the over the long
term the number of workers that are that
are self-employed has actually declined
somewhat according to government
statistics over the last decade or so so
there's a little bit of so there's a
little bit of a push back and since well
is the gig economy really that big a
part of this deterioration of work and
that there's the other thing that some
of the jobs that the gig economy is
replacing aren't like the great jobs
that we think that are gonna support our
middle class so like a taxi driver in
New York is not a great job so you know
over might be you know not an ideal job
at the job that's be that it's hitting
isn't an ideal job either and it's in
fact I'm Alan Krueger former economic
adviser of President Obama actually did
this work for for uber that I I'm sure
you must be aware of I come I comment on
the Krueger report I am I was not
impressed with that report but we could
but his conclusion was that that uber
drivers actually made more than hired
drivers right that they were making like
nineteen bucks an hour on average versus
about 13 bucks for for a cabbie that was
hired by a cab company and so you know
that suggests that you know it's
certainly not a not a fantastic job but
I wonder if this is a real sign of an
unraveling of sort of like the labor
contract in the labor market sure I mean
real quickly on the Krueger report III
was surprised that he put his name on
that because he is you know a respected
economist there are a few things wrong
with that report one it relied
exclusively on ubers data and you know
this is a company that plays fast and
loose with the facts I like to say that
you can trust
Uber's data about as much as you can
trust Chyna's or Greece's data and so
but secondly when he came up with the
how much they get paid they didn't take
into account how much drivers spend how
much their expenses are to drive which
are significant
you know you've got gas you've got tolls
you've got you know just everything it
takes to drive us a car through New York
City and you know insurance and all
these sorts of things and they didn't
take into account that at all and you
know some of the estimates said seven to
ten thousand dollars a year in just in
driving expenses the other thing that
was a problematic about that report is
they they they gathered the data for
that report on October of 2014 they
released the data in January 2015 time
to impress the mayors at the conference
of mayors and a week later after that
conference they cut all the ubers wages
driver drivers wages by 40% so that the
data itself was completely out of date
at that point and yet you still see
people citing that the Krueger report is
somehow authoritative and I just think
that it it really doesn't capture there
have been journalists who have gone
around and written written with with
drivers and gotten pay stubs and all
these sorts of things and and just a lot
of anecdotal evidence out there drivers
are saying we're barely making minimum
wage here they're not making any more
than than taxi drivers maybe some are if
they're really good I don't know what
you have to do to be good but clearly
not everybody has that that that ability
and some drivers are just really
struggling being uber drivers that's why
they last so long I mean 50 percent of
the drivers drive 15 hours or less if it
really paid that much more they be
driving in that platform a lot more than
they are 80 percent of uber drivers
corner Uber's numbers are part-time
workers so so then in terms of the data
on how big is this gig economy yes it's
definitely there's a lot of gray area in
there and and your end you know the the
US government first did a study back in
2005 and since says quit gathering data
on it and so I I I feel like the the way
we're counting this is not capturing
what's really going on out there in the
labor force I'll just give you one
simple example you know the unemployment
rate is coming down well in traditional
economic theory when the unemployment
rate comes down then the employment rate
is supposed to go up they are inversely
related like a seesaw and yet we're
living at a time where as the
unemployment rate is coming down the
employment rate has also been coming
down and it now is sort of holding
steady but it has
gotten back to where it was before the
tooth the the Great Recession in 2008
and so what we're all these workers
going and they have to make money they
have to live well the you know they're
becoming discouraged workers as they're
called they're going into the gray
economy and even Janet Yellen and in
testimony before the Senate Banking
Committee testified that you know
they're not confident that they're
accurately counting these sorts of
workers and so the you know the the the
statistic statistics that are put out
there by BLS they use things like
household surveys job surveys of
employers and so it depends on people
reporting a certain viewpoint and
there's a sense that maybe they're not
reporting accurately because we do see
things like 1099 forms which is the form
that a contractor files with the IRS
those are going way up by 20 percent the
number of people filing Schedule C which
is the schedule you use afoot with the
IRS if you're doing self-employment
those are up by 20 percent so we'll have
to see how it plays out over time my
sense is you know it might be more
hitting certain areas than others so San
Francisco New York City is probably
hurting a lot hitting this era these
areas a lot more than it is baby you
know in mid parts of the country but in
San Francisco my sense is that it's a
quite a deal you know it's really
impacting the labor force in major major
ways and you adding things like robots
and automation and all these sorts of
things and you know some of the the many
statistics we've seen on that that
Oxford University study saying 47
percent of US jobs are replaceable over
the next 20 years people have disputed
that number but still I mean you can't
just you know I mean the response says
well well we've always had technological
change new jobs come along but what
other experts are saying not this time
that the the ability of these algorithms
and the technology to take a job and cut
it down into little bites and hands big
parts of that job often the different
off to different parts of Technology and
the humans job is left to just hit the
button and how much is they going to pay
you to hit that button and they can just
hire anybody to do it as a contract they
don't need to you know to hire
a regular w-2 because the thing that for
people don't know the difference wean
for an employer's perspective if you
hire a contractor versus a regularly
employed w-2 worker you get out of
paying about 30% on labor costs because
you don't have to pay for Social
Security Medicare health care injured
worker compensation unemployment
compensation you know a lot let alone a
paid sick leave paid you know vacation
or anything you get out of all that and
that's part of the incentive of doing
that and we've seen it in the book I
have an example of the pharmaceutical
company Merck
they had a plant in Philadelphia they
sell the plant to another company the
company lays off all 400 workers hires
back all 400 workers and then they
proceeded to make the same drugs for
Merck that Merck was making fun of
itself when he had these employers so so
I mean this is the this is the real
scare that I have is that what the gig
economy it's not as a matter of how big
it is it's it's the it's the technology
its pioneering these apps make it so
much easier to hire and fire people you
know if I'm an employer and you're an
employer and you're an employer and
you're an employer and I can hire all
1099 workers you know contractors and
freelancers and you do the same and you
do the same it's gonna put pressure on
you to do the same and it becomes a race
to the bottom at that point it's what I
call the steroids of the economy you
can't not do it because everyone else is
doing it if you want to compete you've
got to do the steroids to know at the
end of the day the underlying story is
what is technology gonna do to the labor
rate relation to work and I mean for
instance from the taxi drivers
perspective I think that a future and
where there's lots of uber drivers is
not as bad as a future in where every
car is a Google car and there are no
drivers at all and some company called
Google just rents out time in their cars
and go pick you up and that's you know
it seems to be within technical
technology's possibilities but so so so
yeah the job the job constrained future
which is a term that you use in the book
is to me the central the central theme
here and as you alluded to right now
this is this is a fear that we had for a
very very long time I mean we've hadded
at least in since the Industrial
Revolution
and it's always been to date proven
wrong and you're suggesting that right
now there's evidence to suggest that
this time might indeed be different and
yet again to push back a little bit if
you look at labor productivity stats if
technology were really increasing a lot
you'd probably be seeing labor
productivity increasing pretty robustly
because there would be all these
machines and so each worker you'd be
getting more from more profit out of
each particular worker and in fact
that's not happening we're seeing the
contrary so that leads me to a little
bit of you know again a little bit of
skepticism is really technology having
that big bite that we fear so much it's
a healthy skepticism you know I think
again we don't we're not we're not sure
where we are on this wheel yet you know
labor productivity is notoriously hard
to measure there's all sorts of
controversy over even before this about
whether we were really measuring it
accurately so you know I I don't really
I don't know I don't think anybody knows
at this point whether this is good all
flame out and we'll just be left with
you know the same old economy we have
which for the last 25 years wages have
been flat or if you know this automation
and robots and gig economy and you know
they're already using technology for
things like just-in-time scheduling
where they can now tell you know exactly
when their customers are going to be
there and so they tell their employees I
only need you you know two days from now
and I can't tell you your schedule two
weeks from now you know you just have to
be on call basically you have no life
you you need to be ready to come in at a
moment's notice you can't plan childcare
you can't I mean so I mean the
technology is already being used in some
ways that I think are degrading the
quality of jobs whether it will ever
reach the the level of you know which I
I fear it could we'll have to see
I think we don't want to ignore the
possibilities though and because you
know some of there are things going on I
think are alarming ya know I indeed not
I think we have to be aware of what's
happening and try to try to make sense
of and but you know again we can also
allow ourselves to go in a wrong door
identify the problem I was having a
conversation with with Paul Romer an
economist at NYU a little while ago
who's done a lot of work on tech on how
technology affects growth over the long
term and he was suggesting to me that
when the people a hundred years from now
look back at our present moment they're
gonna see this debate over technology
and whether it replaces jobs instead of
complementing jobs as it had in the past
that's very much of a sideshow and
people say well why didn't people think
what happened was China happened
suddenly we got the entire Chinese
population dumped on the world labor
market and that had an enormous impact
on the wages and the quality of jobs
across the world it noted notably in the
United States and that seems to have
been you know in our current fear of
technology that seems to have taken a
backseat and I wonder I mean I wonder
what drives this because I was I was a
young journalist when NASA was being
negotiated and I remember that at the
time there was a lot of fear about how
you know negotiating this trade deal
with Mexico would help would hurt
American jobs because there would be all
these low-wage workers competing for the
jobs that American workers do and at the
time you'd hear all these economists you
know like saying no no you know what
tray doesn't really do that that bad you
know trade is ultimately a win-win
proposition what we're seeing what kind
of like the negative effects that we see
in the labor market are more driven by
technology and sort of like maybe I
think that we were set down that road
and we lost sight of some of the other
really big dynamics that are going on
and to be sure I mean the China and
globalization story has a technological
component right there's a lot of
technology in the outsourcing of Labor
production chains throughout the world
but still I mean I think that is really
perhaps a bigger part of the story than
then it might seem you know from from
reading your book and from reading some
of the other commentaries about
technology well I mean I do talk in the
book about globalization and its impact
but it's not I mean there's so many
other books that have tackled that that
I I don't think it negates at all what
we're talking about when I talk about in
the book I mean it's it's all part of
the picture I mean there is a reason why
for the last 25 30 years wages have been
flat in the United States and and and
many of the jobs have lost safety nets
and
and all these sorts of things it is
partly due to technology but it's also
due to jobs being exported there to me
there's no contradiction there or you
know zero-sum game there are many many
pressures on the economy that are you
know are going to create these sorts of
disequilibrium that we have to cope with
I think you know part of the issue is
that we're not coping with them well if
you look at the types of workers who are
I mean you know the typical worker used
to have one employer and that employer
they worked for for many years and
that's who they got they're kind of New
Deal benefits through well you know for
more and more employees there's no
question that they're working for more
and more multiple employers now and and
each one of them they may be you know
they're driving part they're working
part-time as a hairdresser and maybe
they're driving some hours a week for
lyft and maybe they're doing some other
hours on TaskRabbit
so you know for a lot of workers today
these are the sorts of realities that
they are having to deal with and they're
not concerned about you know whether
they're being catarthans in the
statistics or not they're just wondering
you know how do I get what I need and so
you know that the safety net for example
is not set up for this type of worker or
for this type of economy it was set up
for the single employer type of
situation so I mean I regardless of how
the numbers ultimately work out I think
we have to still look at how to create a
safety net for workers who are working
for multiple employers we have to look
at four ways that to make sure that
people can afford things like healthcare
and have enough to do that and you know
and a lot of the employers now are doing
everything they can to wiggle out of
their responsibilities in that way so
you know in my particular bias is I
share your fear I mean I came to this
part where you talk of a robo reporter
so now there's robots doing the job that
I do and right now they're just mostly
doing like sports scores and market
reports but if they can do that why not
columns right you know you can just
press a button for rye skepticism and
they get the rice catechol column
and I'm out of a job so you know yeah
and so perhaps this is a good a good
moment to try to think about solutions
how do you think what is what are the
policy implications of this and how do
we address this I mean you just
mentioned now when you talk at length in
the book about the idea of taking the
safety net disconnecting it from the
individual employer so that I'm so that
workers can take it throughout their
their their their movement through all
these different gigs I wonder is that
you know is does that cut it well I
think we have to do something to retain
a safety net but it won't that's not
going to increase wages so you know
there's there's a lot of challenges
there but in a multi-employer world I
think we have to create some sort of
what you know what I would but you can
call portable benefits where you could
take them from job to job and not I mean
a lot of workers say are stuck in job
lock you know say oh I'd like to leave
this job but I have a pension here and
if I leave I'm gonna lose my pension or
I lose my health care and so I so they
stay there well if we could create a
system where they can take those with
them no matter where they go then the
you know it would actually liberate to
some degree the the creativity of many
workers who get stuck and actually in
the book what I draw from is that
they're actually are if you look at
construction in and and you know mining
and other sorts of industries
construction of trade industries a
carpenter for example this it's been
this way for many years where they might
have multiple employers throughout the
year they might work two months for one
employer and then three weeks for
another and then four months for another
and so over a course of a year they
might work for six seven employers and
and what they have a system set up for
them an hours bank system where each
employer would pay a certain amount into
an account for that carpenter based on
prorated to the number of hours that
that carpenter works for that employer
and and then that money in that account
could be used to pay for things like
Social Security Medicare injured worker
unemployment health care all these sorts
of things now it worked beautifully in
many instances in those occupations
because they were part of the Union and
the Union
they set up a trust and the union
representatives and the employer
representatives all sit on that trust
board and they negotiate a contract that
all those carpenters are work under for
those employers and so you know we're
obviously Ligon i's labor at this point
is down to about seven percent of
workers are organized in the private
sector and it doesn't seem to me it's
not gonna go up anytime soon so we can't
really have you you know just have it
for union work so I was thinking about
how do we do this for workers in general
and so what I am proposing is that we
create for every work or what I call an
individual security account and that you
know be attached to their social
security term or something like this and
and that worker with the the employer
who that worker works for will pay into
this account prorated to the number of
hours that that worker works for that
employer so if Ober wants to hire a
driver they can still hire a contractor
you know they can hire environment will
but they aren't going to get out of the
responsibility of paying a certain
amount into this individual security
account for that worker and I've done
some of the statistical crunching using
Bureau of Labor Statistics numbers you
know especially for low-wage workers it
works out to about two dollars an hour
above their wage that's not a lot of
money to give them you know to help them
pay into Social Security Medicare
injured work or unemployment healthcare
that would include five days of paid
sick leave and five days of paid
vacation it's not a lot of money and so
you know workers can then work for
multiple employers and each employer
would pay their their fair share I mean
basically it's creating legal parity
between all these different categories
of workers because right now a lot of
employers are in this thing like is this
a contractor or worker well I get sued
whoever's being sued two class-action
lawsuits right now saying your drivers
are actually your employer's not
contractors and and and these these
lawsuits are tremendously expensive take
years to work through the courts by the
time you actually win they've changed
you know they found other loopholes it's
just you just never quite win in these
in these sorts of lawsuits so this this
sort of proposal gets past all that it
doesn't matter what the category of
worker is when it comes to this safety
net
every worker would get it every employer
would pay into
and it's it's basically insurance it's
like social security it's an insurance
you know and and and and the biggest
insurance pool of you always want to
have an insurance plan passed on to the
biggest insurance pool and the insurance
people here would be consumers so those
businesses would be able to pass a
certain amount of that cost on to those
consumers but those consumers will also
be many of the ones who are benefitting
because they're getting a safety net so
in this sense of rising tide would float
all boats with a certain sort of
proposal and this idea is being talked
about more and more Senator Mark Warner
has talked about it and some other
people have picked up on this idea since
I put a paper out in the spring that let
people start passing around an
alternative of course would be to have a
richer a Social Security and perhaps a
more generous universal health insurance
scheme as in many European social
democracies right and so people wouldn't
rely so much on their employer for a lot
of their a lot this is what a lot of
European social democracies do they like
in Europe part-timers and freelancers
attempts there are certain things you
can't treat them that much differently
from regularly employed workers as you
can hear us that's why I mean it's
creates legal parity between all these
different classification of workers so
in some ways it is kind of adopting some
of that model and making a US brand of
it if you will though I would agree with
you I actually I have a book coming out
in May called expands Social Security
now and I'm proposing that we double the
Social Security payout and also how to
pay for it using you know creating more
fairness in the tax code so I think
that's got to be you know these are
sorts of things I think seriously we're
going to have to look at in a much more
rigorous and in serious way than we have
in the past beyond just people writing
op-eds about this servicing Elizabeth
Warren's gonna have to find a lot more
supporters for her idea and Bernie
Sanders too well but you know because in
fact the the portability thing the move
of defined benefit pensions to 401ks was
supposed to solve the portability issue
right and it just basically dumped a lot
of risk in the hat' onto the laps of
workers who really weren't able to deal
with it right and so you know you really
need a much more carefully correct yeah
not only risk but it turned out the 401
K system was a complete failure because
if you're if wages are flat for 25 years
no one's saving enough money to put it
in the 401 K and you know the 401 K is a
subsidy it's it's it's it's actually
called in the in the federal codes an
expenditure because it is an expense
that the government incurs and yet 80
percent of that the benefits from that
accrues to the 20 percent highest income
earners so that's what's happened to our
401k system where it's just good I mean
it's same with you know it to be honest
the home mortgage interest deduction is
you know the most of that 75 80 percent
of that in crew accrues to top income
earners so all these things they put
into place that was supposed to be
incentives and vehicles to help all of
us save have not worked they have
completely in my view failed and and we
have to you know at this point you've
got a lot of industries that are special
interests who are wedded into that
system but we do have to look at how to
unravel it and coming up with something
more like an expanded social security
because it'll be much more efficient
Social Security as popular say even
seventy percent of Republicans say they
like Social Security so why not build on
what works instead of continually trying
to you know tweak what's failing over
the past year I've been talking to a
bunch of these you know
Silicon Valley moguls that are you know
talking about this this wonderful future
that's coming to us and a lot of them do
kind of agree that there is gonna be a
problem in the labor market the
technology will disrupt the jobs and
that something must be done that maybe
and that maybe we need to change the
social safety net or something because
the job markets not going to do the job
that it has done over the last you know
half century or more and the but it
seems that there near-universal
solution is something that I think that
you don't really like very much which is
the universal basic income and I've
heard this from a bunch of people oh
right you know maybe jobs will you know
there will be no ky quality jobs anymore
but we'll have a universal basic income
and people will be able to relax
whatever follow their hobbies travel I
don't know
and we will
and then we will still managed to
maintain a Catalan it sounds like the
old Soviet system we pretend to work and
they pretend to pay us or or or you know
the bread and circuses in Rome in you
know Imperial Rome where they they gave
people some basic food and then they go
to the Colosseum and watch gladiators
hack each other apart and and maybe
that's where we're headed I don't know I
mean it's you know it wouldn't be the
first time I mean if you look through
human history humans have done horrible
things to each other and come up with
some really truly terrible systems of
governance that haven't worked very well
maybe that's where we're headed I mean
imagine you know I can see the movie now
Imperial Rome but with our technology
right and there's a movie that you know
you you want to go to that movie and see
it but you want to be able to walk out
of it at the end right imagine if you
were living in and couldn't walk out and
yet I mean if as if whatever social
safety net we have is tied to jobs still
in some way or form and the quality of
jobs is iterating and the pay is
iterating for a large share of the
workforce it seems to me that that just
that the social safety net alone is not
the oh not the answer that you need to
address through policy like the market
distribution of income and I wonder you
know and there are ideas out there Tony
Atkinson which which you referred to
before have put out a whole book about
how to deal with it with this at the
market lever and he's proposed things
like you know profit sharing which you
also seem to support although in a
slightly different way he says well will
through higher estate taxes we can just
include a capital endowment for every
adult he proposes a government jobs atom
at a guaranteed minimum wage so that
every worker has a set a minimum number
of hours working at a minimum wage and
you could also you could take this
further you could change intellectual
property rights to reduce rents in so
many firms you could type that time
monopoly laws so I wonder what role do
you think is beyond the safety net what
changes would you call for well you know
there's there's a few ways to go about
it I mean
everybody needs to have a certain things
in order to live and you can try to give
them more income more wages to buy those
things which has always been the u.s.
approach but in other parts of the world
instead what they've done is tried to
take some of the wealth being produced
by that society and create these
different pools of social insurance and
use that to design more cost-efficient
systems like healthcare so that the cost
to people is less you know I mean if you
don't if your costs are less then you
don't need as much income and so that's
why you know if you look at health care
the United States compared to France or
Belgium or you know for my previous book
Europe's promised I went all over Europe
and talked to him a lot of Americans who
were living there and had lived in for
you know a couple of decades and lived
into quite a different countries and
asked them who has the best health care
system and you know the answer is I
usually got worried for the most part
France and Belgium seem to have the best
Switzerland is also quite good Germany
is you know also good and you know what
they do is they they create they
designed the system in a way that they
can build in certain efficiencies to
that system whereas here we have this
very ad hoc decentralized system
overlapping layers of bureaucracy and so
we're paying twice as much money per
capita for healthcare for only covering
like 85% of our population and they're
paying you know about half the amount
for covering a hundred percent of their
population so you can design systems
health care child care education systems
in a way that is more efficient more
cost-effective and so I think that we
still have a ways to go in order to do
that that sort of thing so that's you
know one approach that I think you can
do you know in terms of wages the other
thing that I proposed in the book I mean
the Manoa I'm not I'm just not going to
surround waiting for for them them to
give us some sort of guaranteed wage I
just I just can't believe it's gonna
happen it's just I just see nothing in
our history to convince me that that's
going to take place I think instead what
we need to do is pass laws and
legislation and regulations around these
companies like what they have in Germany
which I proposed in the book you know
for example
jeremy has fortune 500 companies like we
do big corporations with names you've
heard of you know Siemens and Mercedes
and Volkswagen yeah Volkswagen gets a
chuckle now and but these companies are
you know these are profitable companies
in Germany by law the workers get to
elect 50 percent of the members of the
boards of directors of these companies I
mean how many people here have heard of
that is called co-determination just a
few hands now isn't that amazing this is
what Germany is doing the you know like
the world's largest exporter of goods
and and and most of us have not even
heard of this we just think all German
corporations are like ours they actually
aren't germans have reinvented the
corporation in essence and we don't even
know about it
Sweden also does this a quite a few
countries in Europe has some version of
this it would be as if you know Walmart
if the workers of Walmart got to elect
50% of the members of the boards of
directors right we chuckle at that and
we smile at that we can't even imagine
that and yet that's what it would be so
I think there's a lot of things we could
do we don't just have to wait for them
to decide to give us a guarantee basic
or living wage we can actually create
systems there I mean we don't have to
create them we just have to copy what's
already been done because many other
countries are already doing this when
you look at all a lot of these
measurements the charts you know the
line graphs here's the u.s. is like
usually the outlier up here in the upper
right of all these these these these
charts and graphs and such things out of
so many of these things and so you know
we just need to be more open to what
other places are doing and start coming
up with the u.s. versions of it I mean
one of the things I proposed the book is
why not do this at the university level
universities aren't necessarily don't
think of them as businesses that are
going to fight this kind of thing so
universities could put in place
co-determination where the workers get
to elect 50 percent of the members of
the Board of Directors get it in place
somewhere here that we can point to and
say it's working here and then from
there you start spreading it to
businesses you know so we can we can do
this in blue states because they're you
know red states right to work say
certainly aren't going to do this but
California that we can do this in New
York you it's almost a blue state the
legislature is
goes back and forth between Republican
Democratic control but so I mean there's
things we can do we don't have to just
wait for the robots to come and take our
jobs in other words yeah I mean and yet
I think that the odds that the United
States somehow becomes a European social
democracy are you know very very very
long but but you know and a point that I
would make is it even as much as I like
European social democracies they're
pretty much in trouble too so just to to
know Germany again Germany has passed
labor reform over the last decade or so
that has really reduced the quality of
jobs even through this concept called
the mini job which really has no sorts
of we know has really no protections
pretty much like an American type of job
and most of the growth and employment in
Germany has come from such many jobs so
and so the stresses that we are seeing
here are very similar to stresses that
are that that that are being experienced
in Europe and even though they do have
better policies to start off with I feel
that they are today too that in Europe
too they're feeling the same sort of
pushing the same sort of direction as we
are so you know I don't see it as a
really you know a fail-safe you know
line of defence well I mean they're
subject to globalization so you know if
we're if it's going to be a race to the
bottom then countries like us are
pulling them down you know so we have to
I mean even the many jobs though in
Germany those workers are have more
rights than what contractors or
freelancers have here they still have
access to health care they still have
access to you know certain labor rights
you can't they cannot those job those
rights can't be taken away for workers
and these sorts of jobs so I mean yes
they are they are squeak they are
feeling that pressure to but it's it's
it's a difference of degree a major
difference of degree in terms of how
much they're going down that road
compared to how much we are and so you
know I think we have to be careful not
to just say well you know it's happening
there too so I guess there's nothing we
can learn there I mean so much of what
we're hearing about Europe these days
has to do with Greece and that has
nothing to do with the types of issues
we're talking about the has to do with
how I mean the the European Union and
European member states are going through
a decade's long process of how United
they want to be
as a continent how much federalism do
they want to have and a thing I like to
remind both Europeans and Americans is
that we went through a similar process
in 1790 we tend to forget that 70 years
after our nation's founding we fought a
civil war and it wasn't over slavery
that's what it has capacity in a lot of
the books it was over states rights and
slavery was just a subset of that we
fought a battle over how much central
government should have should should
dominate over states rights and state
government and you know that was 70
years later so I sometimes like to say
Europe is it's kind of like a planet in
formation it's going to take decades to
play that out we're used to things
changing in our lives on the order of
days and weeks and months countries and
continents chased a change on the order
of decades and that's what's going on in
Europe right now and in some ways it's
kind of exciting but in the short term
it leads to some hair-raising headlines
for sure I hope they can prevent a civil
war exactly yeah so just to end this I
think the the question that jumps to
mind to me is to understand the
political economy of these changes that
that you've identified as necessary I
wrote a column I don't know a couple of
years ago saying well we got the new
deal out of the Great Depression there's
a great what does a Great Recession
deliver to us can we you know can we
turn this crisis into an opportunity
will this you know generate this type of
social policies and change in the social
contract that that might lead us perhaps
in the direction that you suggest and I
think that the answer to that is well no
it has not it did not I'm not sure if
it's you know Ben Bernanke's fault that
he you know prevented a total collapse
of the economy and hence we didn't
really get radical policy at worse
before it gets better
exactly or what but so then what is the
necessary what kind of a jolt to the
system what are the necessary
ingredients for these kinds of political
changes to happen here's my response if
he we have a lot of work to do and the
federal level is dead I mean you know
nothing's gonna happen at the federal
level for many years I don't think you
know just I mean my previous books were
written on
politics and political reform and
looking at our political structures and
you know the reality is is that
Republicans aren't interested in any of
this
and the Democrats besides even when even
when they get majorities seem to fumble
the ball a lot but it's going to be it's
going to be increasingly hard for them
to get majorities because the the the
the demographics of partisan
demographics of the districts and what
have you not due to redistricting abuses
though that as a minor factor it just
has to do with where people live I live
in San Francisco and it's not possible
for Republican to win at San Francisco's
too many Democrats and it's not possible
for Democrats to win in other parts the
country cuz it's too many Republicans
and it turns out most of the districts
or like this out of 435 districts we can
tell you is gonna win ninety percent of
them right now in in 2016 we can not
only tell you who's gonna win we can
tell you the margin of victory because
it's so predictable
based on the partisan demographics of
those districts and here's the thing the
Democrats have become such an urban
based party that it's much harder to
draw districts for them even if you do a
gerrymander or you know what have you
because they're just too concentrated I
mean in San Francisco Nancy Pelosi was
with eighty percent of the vote and
people say well she wanted a landslide
no she actually wasted you know 20 2009
percent of the vote that could have been
given to other districts to let
Democrats win other districts so even
though Obama beat Mitt Romney by what
five percentage points Mitt Romney won
about twenty more congressional
districts nationwide so that's what the
Democrats are facing the uphill battle
so federal level forgetting the battle
is that going to be at the local and
state level that's where it has to
happen and right here in New York City
you can pass a a safety net a
multi-employer safety net for every
worker in the city at the City Council
level it doesn't require federal law to
do that you know you can do some of this
at the state level there's a lot of
things you can pass co-determination
at the state level you can pass some of
these other reforms that are in my book
at the state level or at the local level
you know we have to roll up our sleeves
and get to work
because I mean we can't completely
ignore the federal level because the
wrong people get in there they can do a
lot of damage and set things back even
further but I guess I'm suggesting that
local and state level is where people
have to get get get working
you know you've all heard the Alec
database right it's probably it's the PA
what it stands for it's it's the the far
rights legal arm where they draft
legislation and they have it they have
it ready for Less state legislators who
come and say I need a law on this and
it's all ready to go for you I mean to
hell it's been going for years and the
left never had anything like this well
it now does there's an organization
called 6s IX and so you should check out
their website they are putting
legislation on there for progressive
legislators they are bringing
progressive legislators together into
meetings like Alec has been doing for
years in order to you know help them
start meeting each other you know I mean
it's just organized right we can do that
we know how to do that so open it up now
questions we have 15 minutes we've got
to be efficient about this please if you
want to make a comment do so in a
reasonably length sentence and not a
paragraph or a page and and and a
question there should be one question
again reasonably so its floor is open
thank you great great presentation and
I'm gonna be a little longer than one
sentence but I'll be quick I was
listening to the news you know about
Airbnb and their political controversy
over the ads in San Francisco and it
struck me that what they're looking at
is getting people to commoditize their
assets and they're really looking for
everyone to be an entrepreneur in quotes
in this economy right and and you talk
about that they're not giving pensions
but what exists are SEP IRAs you know
Keogh plans those are all set up but I
don't see people having the
sophistication to do that to work in
that manner and so I'm just curious you
didn't you didn't discuss it today but I
was wondering have you thought about it
and agree with that or you know why do
you see that that's not I don't think
it'll work it's almost like going back
to the agricultural societies we had
where everyone used their assets
whatever they had I in the book I do
talk about this a little bit you know
there's this because a lot of these
sharing economy companies now are
starting to go through the the white
dwarf stage into the black hole stage of
basically owned belly-up because the
whole model was predicated on this idea
that we all can be our own CEOs we all
can be our own entrepreneurs you know
and I'm going to set up a business where
you connect with that you can connect to
and implement you'll be able to sell
yourself and you know go out there and
be your own business
and it turns out that you know for a lot
of people that's not really what they're
cut out to be not everybody can hustle
like that I mean maybe we all should be
able to maybe they'll come up with a
drug someday that makes us all
hyperactive and we'll all be able to but
it doesn't exist right now and so but it
was the funny thing about for CEO of the
dead company was basically saying like
it turns out huh we overestimated we
thought everybody we hired would be like
me a self-starter who wants to start a
new business new company and it turns
out they're not huh who would have thunk
it you know and so somehow you know the
whole basis of their model was founded
on a lot of assumptions about human
nature and and people and they turned
out to not be true
why even like TaskRabbit which was
hailed by you know all sorts of meeting
you Hollis stories about tasks up this
is how we're gonna work in the future
TaskRabbit now has done what's in
Silicon Valley is called a pivot means
their business model is failing their
venture capitalists are saying we're not
sure we want to give you more money and
so they basically have become a
glorified temp agency just using apps
and websites more than other temp
agencies do and and you're seeing this
in a lot of these labor brokerage
websites uber and airbnb have the two
that have sort of kept going and but
even there there's a great deal of smoke
and mirrors involved you don't know how
much money these companies are really
making because they're not public
companies and again all the only numbers
come from them and so they have you know
it's hillock on valley it all lives on
smoke and mirrors people keep giving you
money as long as they think it's getting
better and better and they're gonna make
more and more as soon as they start
thinking the other way poof it all
disappears so they have to keep the
charade going as long as they can I have
a question I had a an op-ed in the New
York Daily News yesterday on air B&B
those PC tests to see how many people
read the New York Daily did anybody see
it darn it you know how much I went
through I took to get that in that paper
and anyway it was on it was on air babe
yeah here's I just so in case we don't
get to here's the quick thing on air B&B
started out as a good idea you know let
people write out their spare homes their
spare rooms and your make some extra
money in a down economy it's a great
idea in certain ways it's morphed into
something completely different it's
morphed into a loophole for professional
landlords and property managers when
real estate operatives to basically
circumvent the law because all the
cities that you know they passed law as
long time ago saying you can't rent for
fewer than 30 days the reason why is
they didn't want their housing stock to
be pitted tourists versus local
residents the housing needs of tourists
are different from local residents and
if you let these short-term rentals you
know too many of them happen then
suddenly your housing stock gets used up
by tourists well so that put that
prevailed for many years and then
Craigslist came along started doing it a
little bit it was still ok was that
numbers suddenly Airbnb comes along and
just busts the whole thing wide open
so that now you have so many people on
there who are renting out I've
interviewed ten and after ten in San
Francisco who was evicted from their
place by a landlord who just wanted to
get him out of there rent controlled
apartment so they could put it on Airbnb
and the landlords are just doing
unconscionable things and they seem to
target elderly people disabled people
people who have language minority
challenges people who have a harder time
defending themselves and and aren't
going to nestle go out and hire a lawyer
to defend themselves they they're just
what's going on in San Francisco is just
really horrible and it's going on here
in New York too in a lot of ways where
these professionals are just taking over
the platform and Airbnb knows it because
they have the numbers and and there are
people who scrape their website and get
these numbers you can see how many hosts
have multiple properties that's how you
know what's going on and and it's it's
it's just taking over the website and
the Airbnb is making money hand over
fist so they're not about to kill their
Golden Goose and they'll just they're
still putting forward in San Francisco
they're voting this November throw it on
Proposition F a citizen's initiative to
crack down on Airbnb they're putting
forward the quote regular people as the
face of Airbnb in their campaign and and
and that's not who that is anymore it's
these professionals who are taking it
over sorry to go on here kind of short
question
let me want impression that I have
actually from today's talk and generally
one problem they also had there seems
there seems to be like two narratives
one is robotics are taking over all the
jobs and basically we would have no jobs
and nothing to do leisure
so this one era - but the second
narrative is that actually work is
really impedin or actually taking more
and more of our normally leisure time at
free time so one narrative seems that
actually we are really should fear loss
of job and lots of work the other
narrative is that we are not going to
have leisure time anymore
so which narrative is really true um I
think they're both true they're not
inconsistent because one has happened
the loss of jobs is going to happen over
time that's what you know sort of the
experts are saying it's gonna happen
over 10 15 20 years it already has
happened
to some degree and in my book I have an
example of in University of California
San Francisco big Hospital Medical
Center they have now a big robot that
can fill prescriptions they can do like
ten thousand a day you know they're
they're just basically making
pharmacists obsolete and what the
pharmacist is going to do in the future
I don't know but you know these these
robots can can they can take the pills
out of a bin they've got a you know they
know who it's going to and and they slap
a barcode on the the plastic bag with
the prescription and it goes up a chute
and goes to the patient so I mean these
are the type of thing that we're being
told is going to happen more and more
but it's going to happen over time in
the meantime in the here and now people
are working harder and longer for less
and you know I think maybe you know if
we extrapolate twenty thirty years from
now if this the doomsday scenario comes
true you can imagine that there may be a
lot of jobs for people still to do but
there'll be very menial jobs and they'll
pay you know next to nothing and you
know if you want to really you know go
with the science fiction scenario you
know the overlords will live in the
upper buildings of upper floors these
buildings they'll have their land
bridges it just it'll be like this is
this is species of salamander in the top
of redwood trees it never steps on the
floor that just lives at the top of the
trees they'll just live at the tops of
the buildings and and the rest of us
will be down here toiling at whatever
jobs are left those pharmacists will end
up monetizing all their time doing odd
jobs you're here in a good position to
tell us what they're gonna be doing if I
could add if I could add to the answer I
mean there's it's we already see it
today right what you it's not like
suddenly all the jobs are taken out and
so that there is no job that pays above
zero but you see it hitting in the wage
and so essentially to acquire a certain
amount of income you just need to work
more right so you see this in the shift
the jobs in the retail sector right now
and this is just kind of an acceleration
what he proposes an acceleration of this
process yeah you know I mean uber Travis
County CEO of uber when he when people
complain about you know their wages
being cut
he says well because our prices will be
lower there'll be more people with fares
you can just drive you'll have more
fares per hour and you know the drivers
like well yeah so I'm just supposed to
drive faster and and you know I mean
it's just speed up but it's not in a
factory but I mean so that I think this
is emblematic of how this sort of
Silicon Valley mentality is and the type
of reality they're expecting us to to
cope with some of the suggestions you
were making about changes at the state
and local level sounded very optimistic
could you talk a little bit about the
political implications because we had a
little incident here where the mayor
wanted to just put a temporary hold on
growth for uber so we could study it and
see what it does to labor to traffic to
all kinds of things and boy did he get
beaten down well you know you don't win
every battle I think well I would I
think the position the mayor took was
correct you know I certainly see it in
San Francisco driving through downtown
San Francisco is way more difficult it
takes you a lot more time there's so
much more congestion now some of them
may be that the economy has picked up
some but you know the economy I've lived
there for many years the economy was
good before it was bad and it wasn't the
traffic wasn't like this there are so
many more uber and lyft drivers and
ride-sharing and sidecar and all of them
you know and so you know I think that if
if you go after that and you try to
somehow rein it in then you if you lose
a battle you have to try it again I mean
it sounds like they had to regroup they
didn't they were not they were not
prepared for the the storm that came and
they're in their direction but here's
the other thing that I would like to
emphasize I mean you know there's some
things about some of these platforms has
some positive aspects to it the uber
technology could be used in a positive
way in fact in Finland they're taking
that uber technology and putting it into
their public buses and they are you know
it's like smaller shuttles and you get
on that that shuttle and you tell the
driver where you want to go and and the
driver plots a route for all the
passengers in real time and they don't
follow a set route all the time they can
drop you door-to-door so there are some
things that can be done with this
technology if we think of our streets
a public utility that's the key our
streets are publicly chilly they're not
for Travis Callen just flood the street
with cars so that he can make more and
more money I mean the medallion system
comes from the Great Depression when
cities like New York suddenly people got
in their cars to make money because they
have jobs and it was just completely
chaos you know not only too much too
many cars in the road but you know rogue
drivers doing horrible things to
passengers all sorts of things that's
where the medallion system came from
well I think we're going to be going
back to something like that where
there's just gonna be so many cars on
the road it's a clash of conveniences
sure it's a convenience to hit your app
and have the uber show up in five
minutes but then if you get in that car
and you're sitting in traffic for
another thirty five extra minutes then
you haven't gained very much have you
because there's just too much congestion
going on not to mention the more carbons
is being belts more pollution it you
know there's we have to really think
about what we're going to do the other
thing that obrah could you certainly end
up doing because now they're talking
about trying to create their own little
car pools but think about this the way
public transportation works is you have
certain lines that are profitable
because you have they're used all the
time and then you have other lines that
aren't profitable because not they're
not using much and yet if you could have
a comprehensive grid of public
transportation you need all of those
lines
well if uber and other these other
services start having a services just
Sprint's up and down the profitable
lines and cherry-picking passengers it
will completely undermine the funding
for public transportation so you know we
really have to think about these things
and design them more carefully dry
rather than just saying
Travis kalak shirt flooded it flood our
street with cars we just love I love
getting the Americans having this great
big fantasy that we can all have our own
private limo that shows up to pick us up
for five minute and five minutes after
you hit the app and and I'm sorry you
just can't do that and not expect that
there's going to be some real downsides
to what's going to happen by flooding
your streets with cars one more question
thank you tonight all the commentary and
the questions have been very
illuminating I want to read I've been
studying contingent work since the late
1980s and they transition an American
Employment Relations in fact I work this
university in a blue state in a union
without a contract for six years just
thought I'd add that Oh in the mostly a
you know mostly looked at at the
identification of higher education and
its associated just demise with American
education and I think these are
important things to consider as we're
talking about this uber is Asian this
has happened to the University it's been
happening since 1973 now here's my
question at the end of your talk you
mentioned just get out there and do it
you know we can't do it federally we'll
have to do it locally well what's to
prevent you know the the elephant in the
room which is Citizens United
from exerting forces in our own state so
we do great things in New York
Connecticut
wherever Massachusetts and those firms
those companies just move out now state
functions can't move that's for sure
public universities can't move you know
although they may think about hiring
teachers from India one day as I've
predicted but how I don't know if it's
really realistic given the intimidation
factors that go on for many of these
workers in these really bad jobs to
become involved to be organizing in a
way that will change their working
conditions unless we're also enlarging
and empowering a national movement at
the same time because I believe workers
in these red states have bad jobs and
they want change - yeah you know there's
many many things to say in response at
first I let me just say thank you to her
Eduardo it's really been fun to do this
with you and thank you to CUNY Graduate
Center for having me and to Janet
Gornick for setting this up and to
yourself so thanks for having me here
it's been this has been a lot
fun you know it's I mean building
national movement sure it sounds great
but I mean it's it's kind of hard to do
I tend to want to focus in on I'm
someone that you know has passed
legislation at local and state levels
and so that's what I know and I know
that when you pass laws it changes
people's behavior and so and sure if you
have a national movement it helps you to
pass the laws so it's kind of a chicken
or egg thing but I think that you know
manure and your strategic and you find
the the the the the policy proposals
that when you can build support around
and then that thing becomes a stepping
stone to the next thing that's that's
the way it's going to be most effective
but it does take time and if we're
wanting quick fixes I don't have any
answers for it it's you know we we we've
gotten into this mess
over the last 25 30 years and it's going
to probably take that long to get out of
it so we better get going on it because
otherwise like I said at the beginning
my fear is we're gonna look back twenty
years from now and we're gonna say we
didn't get this right we didn't we
didn't realize what the potential
problems were going to be and we didn't
anticipate what we needed to do and so
as a result we didn't do it and so now
here we are stuck we're all task rabbits
and pushing buttons for low pay and
let's go see the gladiators tonight what
do you
[Applause]
[Music]